moreover Nala hi oh speaking of talking
too fast below everyone now more oh
you're some kind of Broadcasters hi I've
been known to say a few words over the
years maybe more than most people would
have liked to have heard but one of the
first times I became aware of you is a
miracle cro cop video what exactly did
they did where he kind of puncture yeah
he did Punk me that was set up by the
illustrious legendary El Guapo bas
Rutten who you may know as Rooker from
the CBS sitcom Kevin can wait that
should have been renewed for a third
season so my man could get paid but that
didn't happen he's a fighter of of you
know no to one of the baddest men on the
planet and when I started working in
Japan he helped get me the gig and Mirko
Cro Cop even now even though he's out of
Bellator 200 which I'm doing on Friday
was looking forward to his Bellator
debut uh known for being a very stoic
silent killer type and it was my first
time meeting him and I'd let boss know
that I'm nervous of the guy I will
interview him but I'd rather you do it
so I can get my feet wet and he's like
no no problem so he ends up interviewing
his opponent the guy that I was supposed
to interview and I go an interview by
Mirko and you see on the video what
transpired and that was my third show
with the the company and I thought okay
well this this chapter in my life is
over and perhaps my life is over because
you see him walk towards me at the end
I'm thinking Keyser söze and usual
suspects and where he's walking home and
then boom big head kick right to my face
instead he goes it's a joke so it it's
lived on for 14 years believe it or not
really really frighten or gently front
yeah yeah come on see it coming no and
there was a beeline to the hotel room to
you know I'm glad I was wearing dark
pants that way a change needed to happen
when you're doing all the stuff because
the documentary is coming out on
Showtime on Friday at 9:00 polar rock
and roll which is it's a it's amazing
like I kind of knew your story but the
level to which you revealed in this
thing is like off the charts like it's
as revealing as anybody especially in
your position right because you're in
this position of you you're suffering
from bipolar
but at the same time you're as
successful in broadcasting as you've
ever been
yes you could easily use this moment to
kind of push that aside a little bit let
the good times roll and like let me be
there for my spots and if I'm going
crazy over here in a hotel room don't
worry about it don't look at me sure
like I'll see you at the next show but
instead like you kind of let us all see
not you know it's not just a description
of like what mania looks like when a
manic episode it looks like like what
what if I'm this high right now what do
the lows look like like you see and that
was the entire point see the emotions
you see like you're just pouring yup and
and and Jim I you know not too bright
you're I'm successful comedian you're
you're successful broadcaster what I'm
saying I believe the most successful
people in this industry are touched by
something like Robin Williams said
touched by man is touched by fire for me
it has been a constant struggle of
trying to just for me work as therapy
and because of what you see back up the
documentary had to be as revealing as
raw as uncomfortable to watch or else
there would be no point to it yeah yeah
we all have a unique journey we all had
a dream as kids are you know some of our
dreams came true but the point of this
talk was we write about it we talk about
it sometimes but no one like you say has
made it as clear as we try to do in this
talk what mental illness looks like and
it's the invisible illness we're not in
a wheelchair I'm not on crutches you
know people have this it's all about the
stigma snap out of it you're you're just
lazy or all you're just looking for
attention well here you go this is this
is what it looks like am i looking for
attention or am I am i suffering human
being at times right and that's where
I'm I want to just make it okay to not
be okay it's not just looking for
attention because there's times where
like you know I'd guilt my own not sure
we all do but when you're dealing with
it alone like you're by yourself right
and you're thinking like life is good I
gotta jump off the balcony
yes it's crazy thinking Jim alone in a
crowd I can be and this is it like this
Linus had his blanket these had these
headphones this microphone even though
it's an antithetical to what most people
would say because public speaking after
death the thing people are afraid of or
or
on camera this is my security blanket
and so for me even the moment I take it
off and and you know people milling
about backstage or or people coming up a
man big fan or I'm immediately oh my god
oh my god and and there's this sense of
jubilation because wow you get to call
the biggest fights and you know look at
take over New Orleans man one of the
greatest events ever yeah I should have
been riding that high forever instead
not even moments later I'm like oh god
I'm a fraud oh [ __ ] they're gonna
they're gonna fire me or throw me yeah
yeah it's unbelievable which is why it's
especially unbelievable because you go
over like all the all the shots that
you've gotten and the fact that even
like you talk about takeover in WWE last
year's been ridiculous my man Klitschko
and Josh was put a 90,000 Wembley
Mayweather McGregor second biggest
pay-per-view ever by AJ Styles John Cena
27 times of the year they've all been so
without the condition without the
illness the career from literally
growing up on a dead-end road in a farm
and in you know BF nowhere to to doing
all of this it's bipolar in its own
sense and even now I sense look at me
getting more excited more rapid more I
it just happens is it in a way it's okay
I've described it before I don't know
how to say it's a chemical dump like it
starts the top of your head and you feel
it like wash into your upper chest and
so it can be comforting or it can be
very very well said Jim but it's
something that is you can't describe
what it is but whether it's a sexual
rush or the rush of depression or then
all of a sudden it becomes elation like
it's almost like it's just it's a warmth
it's mental you have a camera in my did
you surreptitiously put a camera in my
life and they're watching because you're
describing it to a team if you have a
toilet I put but honest you you how well
said is that and you just said it's hard
to describe and for us who talk for a
living and do it quite well I would
imagine that's why it had to be visceral
it had to be visual I remember Ron
Howard a beautiful mind Russell Crowe
and how he depicted schizophrenia I
thought for the first time in my life
dealing with what I'm dealing man this
guy he he gets the the poetic the
creative nature of all this because
let's face it and they were bipolar and
definition the I don't think I'd be here
sitting with you guys if I wasn't the
manic part of it I believe that that
has really proved to be the jet fuel
that has let me reach all of these
heights of success sorry there is there
is a positive to the negative that's
what I was about literally just about to
ask when do you look at yourself of God
I'm kind of glad I'm this way because it
fuels me creatively or do you ever go
like I just wish I was like you ever
look at people who were in a happy
relationship and are just content like I
had a great time we watched a movie went
to bed and you're like I wish I was that
person like I would love to know what
that's like to be that person
great question absolutely not because
most relationships I've been subjected
to or just not happy even though they
say they are and that's the other people
always ask well how do you deal with
personal relationships last time I had a
serious relationship was 15 years ago
again a Jenny Knight heart natty sisters
a night hearts daughter yeah she and and
that I've always been drawn to people
who either get me totally or just want
to ride the wave of of mania and and as
you see even in the doctor book we used
to have get-togethers in my friends
place I was a nightclub DJ as well and
it's you know we'd go for hours of
spinning and then we go until 5:00 6:00
in the morning and dinner place just
improvising doing our own version of SNL
or whatever but looking back now sure it
for a first glance that's entertaining
but holy [ __ ] there's something what's
up with and that wasn't on anything I
wasn't on cocaine I was drinking the
only self medication I did before really
trying to find right treatment was I was
drunk 42 days in a row and it wasn't a
good thing but and as has been broached
the only thing I have found to keep me
you know hanging on this Kim Wilde would
say cannabis and I don't know if it's
that what it is in THC that that with my
chemicals or my makeup and this is
what's so frustrating guys as much as
I'm trying to bang the drama we have
Mariah Carey and Kevin Love demar
derozan logic and all of these actors
Jim Norton is doing this thing here
today as well we we need to raise voices
but we still don't know what it is is it
a chemical imbalance is it hereditary is
it a product of our environment I know
that it's multi-generational on my mom's
side especially when it comes to
depression but in terms of treatment we
need more money not less look what's
happening to our military veterans the
amount of feed
back you guys just based on the trailer
that I received predominantly by men and
how open they are and sharing with me
their fears their struggles I had an 18
year old girl from Germany text me this
morning or text me email me this morning
literally saying and it you know I can
breakdown me whatever saying that just
seeing the trailer has inspired her to
get help she was going to kill herself
so for me it's not about being Miss
ionic or the Jesus I want to help save
lives that are beans they're dying
unnecessarily how does it make you feel
like that that's an amazing impact as
you do sports for living shows great
announcing and then you reveal something
personal and you actually realize that
people are like changed by it
this is the god this is why I'm on this
earth honestly Jim I've always wanted to
perform I wanted buddy you have no idea
how much respect I have for stand-up
comedians because to me that's always
been something Wow I'd love to just try
and see and enough the the crippling
debilitating fear of bombing is the you
know it's just so for me it's this I
want to be an advocate I want I've
always looked out for the little guy I
can remember being eight nine years old
at school we'd have hot dog days and 75
cents you get your little chocolate milk
and your hot dog and there was a boy
there about twice in a row he didn't
participate and this is in the seventies
and I'm like I went and robbed change
out of my dad's pocket so this kid could
have part of hotdogs a and I'm not sure
what a great guy but that's who I am
that's how I'm but seriously it's I've
always loved the underdog we all do but
I and I know that in many ways I am so I
wanted to show people look what I'm
doing it's a constant struggle but
talking about it like you guys are
allowing me to do and having just your
support network Sam Jim you're now my
support number I have so many people who
are wanting good things for me I want
others to feel that because people are
suffering in silence and it's costing
them their lives when you go and you
show it kind of surprised me in the
documentary that you you talk about the
cannabis and that's what I'm surprised
they allowed it well that's what's gonna
ask you whether it's because more and
more nowadays I hear from individuals
who have various different ailments that
cannabis is what helps them but I don't
hear that from organizations have you
had any blowback whether it's from
Showtime or WWE
bellator any of these any any organism
it warms the cockles of my heart that I
have had nothing but unmitigated support
and I know why it starts with Stephen
Espinoza and Showtime because
Harris USANA vich my best friend who was
the guy I let in and let you know film
all of this wouldn't happen without him
by the way he deserves
he spent his own money but was away from
his young family for days this was a
labor of love for him because he firmly
believed in the message that we were
going to try to get across but WWE
Bellator but like I say Steven Espinoza
at first said man you know we got to
protect him like this is our guy he's
our voices Showtime boxing and as soon
as he said it he said to himself oh this
is that's the problem right there yeah
we have to show so and yes we are from
what I hear billions of dollars a year
lost to mental health issues people you
know but not being able to work and yet
if you have the flu if you're undergoing
chemotherapy treatment undergoing
dialysis with all due respect to and
I've lost people to every known illness
you've known how can you not then allow
people who are unable to get out of bed
because they're looking at the light
fixture wondering if it can hold their
weight we we without mental health there
is no health I wish people it's it's all
just about the stigma stigma of mental
health stigma of cannabis stigma sports
entertainment professional wrestling
color what you will it's I just want to
get the conversation started I don't
care how vulnerable I am made to feel if
it can save one life and judging by the
feedback already it's doing that how the
hell can anyone give me backlash are you
sexually compulsive or no yes sir what a
great question first time ever asked um
yes sir i i huh Wow cuz this is really
AM you know Ariel Helwani show yesterday
yeah I don't out and I know Jim because
these are the kinds of shows I really
wanted to do because it's not just about
fight talk or this thing that stuff
needs to be addressed I have had I used
to phone 900 numbers and just put the
phone down racking up the bill not even
listening because it was my way of
sabotaging my parents might think Oh
what the hell $900 phone bill what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you and I'm like yeah
there is something wrong with me um but
when I was a nightclub deejay
it was not good and it was all it was
never enjoyable it was just about trying
to medicate and here is that it's and so
even now I am single but I I feel I
can't be in a marriage or a relationship
or bring a child into the world because
at my lowest points I would not wish
what I go through under any towards
anyone so um it's weird man I that
that's also something I think that has
to be investigated because everything's
impulsive I spend money I spent over
$1,500 buying people dinner over the
last two three days just I'm always that
guy I I love to take care of everybody
regardless of the cost so thankfully
Frank Shamrock who the legendary fighter
who's become my best friend and manager
he takes care of my finances and helps
me with my life and I wouldn't be where
I am without people like him so I have
people looking after me otherwise it
would be it would be big trouble yeah
it's it's the 900 numbers it's funny I
remember the years ago the way to do it
was you had to send in a money order so
I didn't have credit cards I sent in a
money order to California and I got sent
back a list of phone numbers you can
call between these hours and I wanted to
jerk off at some crazy hour and I
remember the girl on the phone went what
you want to talk like that it the one
time the one time I called where I
really wanted to talk to someone yeah
she went hello and I said hey how's it
going this is you know mark I think was
mine nomes chair mark she goes not
tonight honey I got an earache texting
gotten you and then they can fall you
got it right here all the time you can't
put it down
yeah I I'm a phone addict for sure
people well here I'll tell you guys that
it was always made fun of I I was late
to the Twitter party I came in 2009 and
guys I have two hundred and twenty two
point one thousand tweets oh my gosh
like you're a very interactive and
you're a retweeting perv what well I I'm
mayor of retweet City as you know and
it's part of my way of trolling other
people on the hey you guys wanted to
create this one
well here you go I'll send you an
avalanche of [ __ ] but uh but look 220 mm
tweet so ever yeah I'm very much a
highly addictive personnel are you a
numbers guy to you like do you keep up
with stuff like that like our 220 okay
yeah well dirty and I got it what's this
say on my bracelet and that's been
another again whether a sign with or
whatever it is you you know there was a
show that was on HBO that was cancelled
already here and now that actually had
the 11:11 phenomenon is one of its
storylines and I'm like I'm it's been
something that's followed me around
throughout my life and I've always
thought well has to be something I look
go online you see everyone's conspiracy
theories for the most part is it's a
positive thing but I am yeah quirky in
that way and and and just you know the
memory of names and stats in in what
that's why I the condition has really
helped my career but the personal toll
has been severe what do you like as I
would like when you are you do you get I
love it are vicious and I saw your movie
screen you forget that there's no person
I guess super loud and I get I go to the
jugular I have a like yourself I got a
very good vocabulary but I at at my at
my angry Asst the vocabularies gone and
it is it is very hurtful and that's the
other thing like I've you know
threatened my family's life when I was
very sick I've obviously threatened my
own but I and it's I go from being the
sweetest human being I'll never forget
when I was at a nightclub DJ was baiting
the bartender and I was so looking
forward to seeing her beautiful girl hey
honey I come in I say hey honey how's it
going I go into the DJ booth put the
records down she comes up starts
massaging me what the [ __ ] are you doing
I'm like and and the funny thing is guys
this is what really strange to me it's
almost like I remove my I get out of my
body and I see what I'm doing and I
can't stop it say watching a film it's
like watching it from another room and
then you realize you've hurt a real
person yeah and you're like oh no so but
what I'm a lot of times they say you
know I've undergone blackout moments I
guess where people have told me that hey
this happened I'm like wow I don't
remember that but I remember even now 20
years later 25 years later the
what I was doing so why did I do it why
you know you don't and and so I get why
you want to keep it quiet
why you want to just stay in your little
corner of the world but when I was doing
that that's when I was looking at the
ceiling saying okay so I've been there
I've been suicidal and I have lost too
many people to suicide and judging by
the feedback both online emails and
Twitter there are people suffering right
now that need to see what I'm putting
out there it's the rush of the anger
that's what it's that rush you get it's
like doing it's like doing a [ __ ]
popper the rush of that anger that's it
that becomes more important than the
person you [ __ ] hurt yeah is keeping
that high go yes oh it's chasing the
dread like when I was starting my career
at 16 out of high school I was the motor
al Tomko all-star wrestling was doing a
charity show my high school and I've
from the womb was a pro wrestling fan
and at four or five I visualized I
visualized I'm gonna work without
knowing the term what it meant the fort
for this company I visualize being on
American network television I visualize
calling the biggest fights and where
that I did visualize myself on stage
telling jokes okay I haven't done that
yet but it's like I have but shouldn't
have believed me you are amazing my
friend and I love just like I save in
this conversation means a lot to me
because it's it's cool to have someone
also sharing what you're doing and maybe
you do a lot which I appreciate but for
me even looking back then they were like
holy crap you're a natural on the stick
your energy this and that but when I
look at the inner because we have VHS
tapes from my TV show my life has been
on camera all of it right and so I'm
like holy crap man I've looked like I'm
on cocaine or something but it's it's
just me the the rush
so the documentary is bipolar rock and
roller and it's Friday at 9:00 p.m. on
Showtime so in it you talk about a
period that I was obviously aware of
when because there were a couple of
spots
Showtime was one of them in WWE was
another one where you had to walk away
come to your surprise both organizations
called you and said no no no no no we're
gonna find a spot for you we're gonna
welcome you back in so because I'm so
attached to the WWE short immunity I was
aware that when you kind of when you
disappeared from WWE at first people
didn't know you had had a breakdown
people really a lot of people didn't
even know about the bipolar shroom and
what ended up happening was there was a
lot of scandals on the internet and
bullying this and
other other people we're getting blamed
for that did you think that that was a
fair thing or were you kind of going
like this isn't true yeah it very tough
time personally because it took me until
the age of 46 and my best friend Michael
Jansen who died in nineteen who really
his death is what triggered my first
meltdown that led to the diagnosis a
heart attack believe it or not and his
family all his to his sisters and his
mom and dad just arrived today they're
here for the premiere I call them every
year where no matter where I am July 6
the anniversary of his death but to get
your court the reason I say that when we
were 18 I'll never forget I picked him
up at his college class and all he said
was I can't wait until you work for
Vince McMahon so that was when he was 18
it took me until I was 46 to get to WWE
incredible feedback amazing you talk
about you for you talk about the mania
there the rudder you know working with
Jerry Lawler right away every incredible
run I quickly realized wait a minute as
as tough as this schedule is and though
you know and my man what these sports
entertainers these athletes 52 weeks a
year guys it's amazing real and I've
just did announcer so take that and add
Showtime championship boxing Bellator
MMA other field like I had this all
other two careers going on I thought I'm
Superman I can maintain no I I the
schedule the the the just the stress of
doing all of it was starting to take its
toll
I and so yes you can you know I don't
want to dress anything else because all
of that is [ __ ] and there were
people that of course every working
relationship you have you have to
navigate you're not always gonna get
along with with everybody the way you
would like to get along with with your
colleagues but WWE like you say for all
of its you know the the giant
corporation that it is and and and and
anything you may have heard Paul
Levesque Triple H Michael Cole they
called me and said you know we got to
try we know
the quote from Paul Levesque was moral
maybe I'm wrong but III think pro rata
you know this business is in your DNA
and I said absolutely right
how can we make this work and it's funny
because when they first approached me
and they said we want you to come and
work with us I said is it for NXT
and that's I loved the underdog the
grinder so it it worked out for the best
and I truly believe that this
documentary because I've heard from a
lot of WWE folks and honestly whatever
it's hopefully gonna help them as well
because all of us we need to just
release and instead of Jim as we've
discussed already doing things harmful
to ourselves or others just hate what's
the question you hear most every day hey
how are you what's up do we really mean
it do we actually listen to the answer
and do we think about you want to hear
the answer which night would you listen
to yourself if you're watching a tape of
a fight or something and you hear your
own voice yeah I did a good job or do
you think Isis thank you buddy within
minutes I pick up the first mistake that
I've made and it's [ __ ] off it's done
and I've and and whether it's the way
everyone's got our process I hear a lot
of performers a lot of actors don't
watch their work either to me it's it's
releasing it whatever it is whether you
like it or you don't whether you like
the pop culture references or the energy
or you don't to me it's just it's mic
there it keeps me alive so no I'm never
satisfied and honestly even now I got
these headphones on listening it's like
people always say man you always talk
like that is that your voice yeah it is
and I've always my oh you're you sound
like an announcer well I'm an announcer
I can talk like this and maybe get some
Disney work I hope voiceover work no and
so I understand how everything is picked
apart when we put ourselves out there
and I truly understand how this is going
to be scrutinized but this is my magnum
opus in terms of what I wanted to do for
Humanity and the fact that I've already
hopefully saved or impacted in a
positive way a few lives that's fine I'm
willing to be a casualty for the cause
when you were going through weight I
mean when you when you were working
everywhere that you worked before you
got to WWE where you had your career you
already had your gear right yeah was
there before you're 46 this feeling of
like I still want to get to WWE or was
there more like no I found my niche I'm
you're doing what I'm in by the time I
guess I hit the 40's well I guess before
I did New Japan Pro Wrestling on access
TV I probably still had well you know
would be nice just to have that on my my
my resume but when I didn't you Japan
into the feedback I got for that like
I've always again I don't I don't want
to be famous I don't want
be what I wish I love what I do but it's
I don't need all the other stuff so for
me I love that underground feel of even
New Japan at the time were the you know
the cool kids in the corner as it were
and I satiated my pro wrestling
commentary so by the time I did that I
was fine
so WWE and it funny Michael Cole
followed me on Twitter and like this the
guy is this Michael Cole so I went and
and the email came shortly thereafter
and the rest you know they say is is
history but I who's the first guy who
had an iron here for you that I mean did
somebody tell Michael Cole yeah Cole
died aware I believe that Paul Levesque
Triple H had heard he you know he walked
Floyd Mayweather - yeah one of his
fights oh and he's a boxing fan Michael
Cole was actually a boxing fan so I
believe that I'd maybe been on their
radar for a bit and then when they made
the move to USA Network live I guess
they wanted to bring someone in with
them maybe a little bit of cachet when I
put together the sizzle reel you'll
appreciate this Jim I also was asked um
Warren Buffett every year at his
shareholders meeting Berkshire Hathaway
they do this entertainment video of him
well the year when why how many years a
couple years now he fought Floyd
Mayweather at MGM Grand in Lionel he got
in the ring they filmed this thing with
all these celebrities talking and I'm
the voice of the fight and I'm mad
living you know me making my whatever
comments riffing off this thing and and
and Vince McMahon saw that and went holy
[ __ ] if he can sell that he will get it
would get oh do you the moment you start
your the moment you look back on and go
like oh god that was broadcasted yeah
the worst
yes what September 2007 I believe Hawaii
Gina Carano Tonya Avenger Tonya Avenger
had said on the the press conference I'm
here
I would I wish I could make out with
Gina but I'm here to knock her out she's
okay that's fine you know and at the
time it was great to see that kind of
conversation going there was a lull in
the fight and I used the quote on the
air just say hey this provocative quote
and so I say in Bill Goldberg my
broadcast partner I'm not going to touch
that with a 25-foot pole and I instantly
again trying to be creative ad-lib go
nuts trying to make eye
even my original intention was still
stupid and Goshen should never been done
but I said oh I wouldn't mind if they're
gonna kiss I wouldn't mind touching with
a 25 centimeter pull mean I'd like to be
close to see them kiss
obviously sure it became where everyone
thought well I was referring to the dáil
part of my anatomy thank you and and so
and I was I was destroyed and I know how
upset and rightfully so Gina and Tanya
were by the grace of God they're both
class acts and Gina Carano is is just
one of the most amazing human beings
I've ever met and we were able to put
that behind us I hope but I did lose the
show I was suspended rightfully so my
show time could have lost my entire gig
but again the the understanding being
what was my stupid original intention
and and a court of law I probably would
be found guilty anyway of trying to sell
what I was originally trying to do but
even that was stupid so that was the low
point for me as a broadcaster did you
see the I'm sure you've seen it the
video that WWE put out from the pinhole
camera mouse table you yes I have and
even that it's funny family friends
who've known me forever say what's the
big deal it's like everyone just
figuring this out now but it's yeah it's
w/e has a there's a pinhole camera in
all the announcers tables it's really
just used for communication between the
Bosch in the front but they record
everything and so I guess they saw this
and tell me what I was doing at the
table in New Orleans and I mean when
he's doing his commentary he's up he's
standing he's jumping his throwing his
arms yeah I mean he's really yeah moding
and I guess they hadn't seen anything
like this before so they put out a
montage of just maro
you can't even see the action you just
hear my call and see it morose physical
everything man mania and it went it's
gone yeah that's great people and it's
funny how many people hey in fact how
many haters have said wow it is genuine
it is well have a sort of a new respect
for you Suren and I'm like it's I mean I
appreciate that but again there is that
tinge of mania right and I believe it's
okay
the same thing you can you you can you
can you can utilize it right you can you
can tunnel it sure push it through this
construction thing it's just it once the
show's over is when you have to then
start to do
the same thing that makes you so good at
that yes the same thing that will make
you go home and hear the Robin Williams
hung himself about that Myra scarpatti
that's amazing man when he died
I was full of because I've been who
isn't I've been walking talking a
tribute to to Robins love the guy and in
fact got to meet his son Cody and even
that's it so if the forrest gump of
broadcasting I tried but he went when he
died people right away oh all of a
sudden are you okay are you okay are you
okay because it was weird that it took
like again a giant of the the
entertainment industry to take his life
knowing what he was suffering through so
that's the other reason for the doc Here
I am I'm not gonna I'm not dead but I
want and and I hope to god I died a
peaceful you know death in my sleep and
a hundred and eleven years old mr.
Roberts but but see his look at what why
did he have to die for for everyone to
say how are you okay you okay do you
know what I mean yeah it's we don't need
to lose anymore we've lost enough let's
let's keep this conversation going like
this documentary that's promoted
properly bipolar rock and roller you're
such an open guy and you're so revealing
it's on Showtime this Friday 9 o'clock
and it's Mauro Ranallo
on Twitter yeah and it's I'm really glad
you did this and I know that I give my
wife's family she has a family member
that suffers from the same thing and I
watched this with her and at first she
goes I don't I don't want to see this
close to home for sure I bet she watched
the whole thing and she liked it finally
even though there is a human trace to it
for her and for AI and and it's it's to
see the highs the lows you see you in
these private moments is like okay we're
starting to wrap around you and this
idea that like where some people go like
well it's a core it's a cry for
attention it's that Mauro's story is so
great because you've got a guy that is
so singularly focused on this goal and
bipolar is so destructive to that goal
that he wouldn't be this isn't it
doesn't make sense no so you cry for
attention because all moral wants to do
is what he's doing and all he's got is
this thing in his brain don't and don't
get me wrong that again Andy Kaufman
never idle of mine and he
when watching it to be honest I'm like I
couldn't it's because I'm so warped I
think I could see where people go wow
this is a pretty interesting piece of
performance art but why I'm sabotaging
my own thought presses you guys mean I
go yeah I could see where people see it
makes it harder the attention you get
from it does not outweigh the negative
of what it is sure absolutely not and
that's why as much as it even hurts me
to the core to say you know I love kids
I love people obviously I want to help
people but I I just can't imagine having
a loved one like my child go what will
through what I go through because I know
what is done to my parents even my
brothers and all of my friends like the
ripple effect that the toll it takes on
those who really care is man it's a gut
wrenching well everybody's gotta watch a
movie bipolar rock and roll or Friday
9:00 p.m. morrow so glad you oh man this
has been a thrill guys and Sam always a
pleasure working with you of course I'm
Jim honestly man a big fan of all your
work and things being so kind in destiny
you as well caring that really
appreciated Jim